you had a dinner with heavyweights
dinner with just some of the biggest
stars a lot of comedy stars yeah music
stars yeah
Chappelle was there Eddie Murphy was
there Chris Rock yeah was there Chris
Tucker uh sure
I mean Dwyane Wade was there Gabrielle
Union Gabrielle Union you get a bunch of
people like that together who picks up
the check
well I'll tell you what it for damn sure
wasn't me I'll tell you that you know
you got to go to those things always
acting like you want to pay and I think
that's how you get out of it you have to
be the the one that's most vocal about a
real quick guys I don't I don't mind
taking a bill let me breath you're on
sir just just screaming out yeah hey ma
can you give me the bill and they always
go oh such and such took care of it and
then you gotta have the biggest like are
you kidding me man what like Chris Chris
Rock pay it's rock papers right paid it
but I I threw a fit like you got to be
kidding me man
I wanna pay it I'm the youngest I look
up to you guys to not let me pay to I
bet you even have any money on you had
nothing
[Applause]
picture yeah yeah that's a picture of
you guys
if you look closely about back pockets
they're empty there was no wallet
there was nothing I'll be honest with
you you can tell that Chris was unhappy
with the bill but definitely he got the
most money probably Eddie Murphy in the
background so happy he didn't have to
pay it yeah yeah and and there was a
Dave actually ordered the most
unnecessary stuff like Dave kept he kept
ordering it like caviar he was like I
don't even eat this stuff man I just
know I'm not paying coming out they was
like man I would have bet do it I don't
know i'ma taste it I would take
advantage of the opportunity
I bet was anybody recording because I
had so many funny people in one room
that's the thing where people think oh
my god wouldn't have been great if there
was a record of all you funny guys and I
can be honest man the the great thing
about these dinners you know we every
once in a while you know we have them
and it's good because the conversation
and the stories that come out of them
are just amazing but Eddie Murphy is the
funniest person on the planet yeah
it's like literally when I mean we leave
the dinner and you know me rock and Dave
will just text and let you know he's the
he's the greatest of all time yeah it's
so effortless and how funny he is yes
every story every story is amazing every
story has a punchline to it and you find
yourself in all of not just who he is
and what he's accomplished but just
you're watching him still do his craft
at the highest level without even
realizing that he's still doing this
crap that's like it's unbelievable Eddie
Eddie pound-for-pound just kills every
time we do it and then afternoon Davis
funny okay
I am I'm today I am available I am I am
completely I'm completely available
I was a slide-in to that dinner to come
yeah then I would think would fit in
beautiful I emailed you do you still
have your hotmail address
that's why do you have you are you still
like Conan at hotmail.com yes no it
hasn't been that yeah yeah that's the
mix-up we sent you a waiter it's
sometime
you